[Music]
everyone's been talking about you and
weights
they're saying you toss this salad i
mean i've never even
heard of dressing someone salad
we were only gone for like a minute yeah
it's long enough for weight
you are here as a part of god's plan
his spirit moved each of you to sign up
for this retreat
hi alice right yeah welcome
it's okay if you think things are
totally weird
i'm gonna need your cell phone and watch
you won't be needing a watch this
weekend anyway
because you're on jesus's time
see ya
alice's retreat isn't going to do you
any favors if you're not honest
so have you ever felt turned on
[Music]
i bet you actually did toss wade salad i
don't even know what that means oh my
god quit the act
you've got mail i am friends with a
pervy psycho
oh then i'm all wet calm down gable not
that wet
yeah you know the truth is
nobody knows what they're doing any more
than the rest of us
[Music]
what are you doing
we're all hiding stuff
all kinds of stuff your body is a gift
from god you need to honor it
say jesus christ jesus christ
you